what is going on there citizens of the reject
Nation thank you so much for being here I
am about to watch a movie I literally know
nothing about but it has been highly recommended
if you like the movie reactions here all you
got to do is comment leave down your request
if uh if I haven't seen it it goes on the
list and then I tend to go by like I don't
know I got a weird metric for what I decided
to do either way just leave your leave your
request down below I'm gonna watch this movie
called the bad guys comes from Dreamworks
and I have a feeling I've been getting requested
for this because I covered Megamind recently
and I love that movie a lot I've heard this
is a good one uh it came out this year and
I haven't seen a trailer or anything for it
so I'm going in very blind to this but I'm
I'm trusting y'all that this is gonna be honest
if I don't like it but trusting you guys on
this leave a like that'd be very much appreciated
subscribe and click the notification Bell
in case we got something that pops up on your
feed from us so you're like yeah that sounds
like a good thing to watch from them also
full-length Reaction watch along is where
you sync up with your own copy of bad guys
and more over at our patreon page for super
sexy rejects cover a whole bunch of stuff
over there exclusively with the reaction highlights
and watch along is included let's swing into
action and see what the heck the bad guys
is all about sea animals see a wolf awesome
oh I'm an animal lover you might see some
cats walking by once in a while in this video
[Music] I don't need presents I don't want
decorations and I'm not a cake Guy seriously
though you don't like cake name one food better
than cake guinea pig looks like Pulp Fiction
now I know the exact moment our friendship
died
let's bounce yep these two voices are so recognizable
who are they [Music] oh like Pulp Fiction
is that intentional he's also my best but
today's his birthday at relevant he's a sweetheart
you're a sweetheart he kind of sounds like
Sam Rockwell is this Sam Rockwell I get so
hung up on these movies I'm trying to figure
out the voices now and over here is Miss tarantula
our in-house hacker our pocket search engine
our traveling Tech wizard we call her web
nice happy birthday Mr Grumpy pants I think
I hate you they're bad guys but they're a
family and this is Mr shark Master of Disguise
apex predator of a thousand faces Mr piranha
he's Brave he's Fearless uh who am I kidding
he's crazy cool animation of course I didn't
forget you know you fart when you lie right
what no I fight when I'm nervous yeah nervous
about lying sorry oh no eight legs Aquafina
that's who it is [Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
this like an action movie Jesus foreign
oh my goodness
the cake
the cake I really love the way the streets
are brought to life the hard life streets
oh my God look at him I've never liked a snake
more in my life take it oh yeah yeah me please
sucker come on man now you gonna make me get
all aggressive [Laughter] okay I'm pretty
sure the shark is Craig Robinson these so-called
bad guys are really just second-rate husbands
really another bank is nothing but a deep
well of anger fine angry you're angry
and those are holes that no amount of cash
or Priceless are can ever fill oh you were
egging them on for tomorrow night I will present
the golden dolphin to this year's goodest
citizen looks like they're gonna go after
the golden dolphin Now snake what better way
to wipe that smirk off the governor's fuzzy
face than stealing the golden dolphin from
right under her whiskers you're in over your
head wolf oh yes did I not mention that that's
weird I thought I mentioned that it was the
Good Samaritan is a guinea pig oh here we
go so step one we'll need to blend in
okay so this is like a heist movie first can
only be opened by a special key card that
is carried by our dear friend the chief of
police the second is outfitted with a retinal
scanner and guarded by an elite special ops
unit trained to strike first and ask questions
later hahaha
interesting piece trashy pointless and pretentious
they say that art reveals more about the viewer
than the artist Mr poodleton Oliver poodle
okay smoothly Legacy there's cementing his
life in prison did you see their last job
unsecured exits crude disguises compulsive
showboating I mean it was a mess if you look
closely enough even trash can be recycled
into something beautiful God it's a swan I
can't miss a photo op with the governor in
a pile of garbage oh
I got that pretty late too
[Applause]
[Laughter] that's cool [Music] no that's okay
no my biggest fear is the snakes in the toilet
in case you didn't know that about me it's
a real fear of my thought that
was a snake for a second dolphins
oh pardon me ah terribly sorry not a problem
sir keep your eyes open boys terrible cops
[Music]
are you okay ma'am I may be dizzy but I'm
alive thanks to you
kill her you're such a good boy oh no is he
about to have an existential crisis
oh no no complete the heist first
oh God [Music] oh good yeah yeah um get your
head back in the game please be subtle [Music]
I'm having a baby why go for subtlety my God
that worked so well
it's kind of like a zootopia heist movie or
something huh [Music] no way that would work
in a movie with talking animals I am questioning
the believability this is going surprisingly
[Music] time to turn this baby on beast mode
it's kind of cool this award is
[Music] [Applause]
disgusting come on I'm starting to get mad
here Larry he's crying [Music]
no don't pass out is this the ladies room
oh uh you need to take a right at the end
of the hall ma'am
oh come on oh my God the golden dolphin
no no please don't panic just stay calm you're
the worst Governor I did these these things
because of how they made me feel no [Music]
and when you're good you're laughed
shout out stop calling him wolf bad guys with
your hands up
run suckers [Music] [Laughter]
right now whoa
no the good in you got you in trouble sadly
we were never given a chance to be anything
more than second-rate criminals if I can prove
to everyone at that Gala that the bad guys
have changed will you set them free and give
them a clean start no what a crazy plan hi
Rupert marmalade IV will turn the bad guys
into the good guys I have a feeling you might
do all right we're gonna pretend to go good
and then we roll into the gala as good guys
and roll out scot-free with the golden dolphin
you guys you might actually turn good they
say experience is the best teacher and they
are wrong I am cocky [__] it's not a butt
it's a lamp in the shape of the love crater
meteorite my greatest I wonder whose butt
it is once again inside there's a flower the
flower of goodness and when it blooms and
you feel that tingle of positivity radiating
through your body you're going to want to
feel it all the time oh my God you're conning
your friends so you can be good I'm going
to give you a push pop right to share why
well on a fundamental level it's about putting
someone else's needs ahead of your own ah
great nope sucker I like Sharon it's yummy
totally worth it well that's terrifying yeah
look it's a cat stuck in a tree I want you
to smack it get it stab it saute sing to it
save it all right right [Laughter] oh that
cat is obviously defected Mark Maron that
is an animal testing lab within 200 000 helpless
guinea pigs all being poked and prodded oh
God no snake is gonna have a hell of a time
here but this is a place for good so I brought
something more friendly for you to wear
oh my God I hope they're bugged they're kind
of like the suicide squad hey there Sirens
Dad I know you've got an important job [Laughter]
I've been waiting my entire life for this
moment okay God damn I got it I've never seen
him so chipper he's gonna eat all the guinea
pigs
oh snake attack this is so bad just keep your
eyes blue to that door okay come on snake
open up relax oh my God oh my God no spinning
them out
20 seconds [Music] [Applause]
it's not what it looks like no they're telling
he's telling the truth I'm sorry Professor
but I'm calling the chief please come on experiments
you couldn't help yourself so I had a moment
of weakness sue me it's gonna be difficult
to do from prison guys what do we do now you
keep the suits even if by some miracle we
did change who's gonna believe us huh of course
you wouldn't know anything about that with
your little miss perfect power suits but you
could form your own identity man a wolf and
a fox are not so different don't do it for
them do it for you this is a chance to write
your own story oh that's a nice message you
don't have to be the big bad wolf good soft
wolf you guys ever seen a baby wolf
it's
so easy to spooky cat
come on Kitty come on Kitty
oh
this is so adorable you you film that yes
and they're starting to like you you're really
getting it really oh thanks it's a shame that
you have to carry all that baggage what you
have great potential but at some point you're
going to have to choose between your friends
or the good life um good life or John
the plan wherever to change you you tell me
right you have my my word go bad oh you ever
wonder what it'd be like the world loving
us instead of being scared of us humor you
ever think about that I don't waste time thinking
about stuff that's never gonna happen uh I
can't wait for things to get back to normal
my dude don't become a self-fulfilling prophecy
put that energy out there you could find a
way to be a good guy you attract you know
you'd be good you attract good all night will
be on you tonight not me friends mate the
good guys
oh my God they're light foreign
[Music]
[Music] [Applause] look at me [Laughter]
oh my God I have to say I'm a little disappointed
I was hoping you were gonna ask me to dance
oh my God wolf
that kind of behavior will get you out of
office Fox how does it feel to have everyone
not fear you for a change
it feels good God damn it no this is going
to lead to some embarrassing moments damn
how much money did there raise that's a lot
of money
professor [Music]
do it a professor oh no [Music] Professor
marmalade
chief that's not the plane what is happening
he's going rogue he's going good it is a pleasure
to Grant the bad guys a full talk
the meteorite is gone
no did this so long suckers
but they didn't do it oh my God is the guinea
pig really awful I was just thinking there's
no real villain in this movie
there's some cool animation I don't even know
how to describe it we're really good now he'll
tell you tonight's headline change is impossible
you should always judge a book by its cover
[Laughter]
of course you didn't do it how could you after
all you're such a good boy we're the legendary
love Creator meteorite will be on display
for the first time ever all eyes will be on
you tonight not me there was his con it's
the ultimate power source you see when it
struck scientists found that it emitted an
electromagnetic frequency unlike anything
else on Earth okay he fell for every one of
my traps starting with saving a helpless little
old lady what's he talking about did I say
too much you little Ginny bastard that's not
a racist but I'm talking about an actual beginning
this is so upsetting I'm giving it all back
[Music]
wow what raft is this don't want to be a bad
guy anymore huh and us your lifelong friends
we're just holding you back yeah maybe you
are you don't sound like a good guy right
now wolf [Music]
what [Music] is that the fox
oh cool
classic
nicely done wait a sec you're the Crimson
ball oh my God stole the zimpango diamond
twice once for profit second time just for
fun never identified never caught I guess
I'm still the best bad guy the world has ever
seen I actually did not see that coming at
all
[Music]
this is a nice reveal it's probably very predictable
for everyone else but me can't do it alone
you know his compound better than anyone you
can count on us right guys guys we're through
wolf done finito is it Mark Maron or Danny
DeVito I cannot tell when you grow up a snake
nobody shows up to your party out there I'm
just a scary good for nothing monster but
nothing compares to having the one guy not
one guy oh trust stabbed me in the back
uh-huh that's sad
[Music]
there are times the animation has like that
motion of into the spider-verse a little bit
the action motion at least okay
what do you saying we have some fun no [Music]
let's try DC League of super best came out
this year there was an evil guinea pig in
there too all I saw in the end was the tricky
Fox that they always told me I was so now
instead of hurting people I'm helping them
I'm still me oh I'm just me on the right side
don't let others opinion of you define you
[Music] holy wow
because this stuff is nice too oh damn what
if you put the close to his lips it's a joke
the greatest Heist the world's ever seen that
is brilliant we have to steal the meteorite
that was very cute yes as though as it was
[Music] wow that looks real doesn't look like
animation in times uncanny where is everything
[Music]
all right okay okay here here take it what
he did something good did you just do what
my friend was sad I was just cheering him
up you you did a good thing oh my God snake
ridiculous I just put your needs before my
own
I think wolf was right maybe we could be more
than just scary villains
oh my God they're all flopping always be bad
guys
damn he looks pretty scary when he's mad
[Music]
that's a mean con [Music] now we're back to
another car chase why would marmalade leave
the golden dolphin unprotected because maybe
it's a trap or maybe
but how did you know we'd even be here oh
I got a little tip from a friend hey buddy
how's it hanging what
horse and gas don't breathe what is that that's
not poisoned yes sorry it's the piranha farts
I can't believe it's you you were right Wolfie
we felt the wag man it's good it's super moving
but can we do this later feels like I got
a Rhythm Section in my fin
guys am I happy to see you
oh look at all that love it's not don't mind
us just robbing this place
Oh I thought snake was in on it he really
did betray them
wow what a cool shot
I do like the way these action scenes are
are realized later boys dear Crimson paw you
are something yeah that's cool
oh she is so badass
nicely done it's like anime [__] in this
okay
you keep that kid an extra safe I swear
the next move so it's my fault snake I was
hoping snake was in on the toll ruse do you
guys think they'll throw the party yeah with
pinatas
y oh go back for snake we can't do this without
he might be a Mr Grumpy pants but he's our
Mr Grumpy pants great [Music] I'll give you
one last chance to give me the meteorite oh
yeah what you gonna do whiskers this
that's a whole lot of guinea pigs
Ah that's kind of terrifying
there's some wild ass animation thank you
[Music] hey let's dial this down a notch huh
besides you'll never get him he's too gonna
drive her I know look how excellent job he's
doing maybe it would be better to exploit
his grace this week exactly exact way
cat ham okay okay you win you can have the
space Rock good boy I mean I feel like snake
could have made it
[Music]
oh I love how it actually came back around
you want him he's yours
snake
a reference to Metal Gear Solid in case you
guys don't know [Music]
guys I know it's crazy but we're gonna jump
it crazy you're finally speaking my language
you just probably killed some of those guinea
pigs by running your car into them
I was afraid that if you knew I I wanted to
be good that you'd act like a jerk and never
talk to you again oh these guys I love you
too buddy oh do you know how beautiful this
is you guys now you're gonna make me cry [Laughter]
who said it was the end
wow that's a really long fall what do they
grapple onto
God damn the human strength on her we're done
running away yeah yeah yep Chief do what you
need to do what but now she wouldn't want
to it's time we took some responsibility it
started clean slate you finally did it this
is your moment Chief drink it in wow you know
I should I should give a speech well I I should
shouldn't I uh that's not necessary I'm proud
of you wolf you know a fox and a wolf are
not that different you'd both eat that cat
he's bringing the meteorite back huh I guess
yes springing bringing it back that's precisely
what I am doing Dan that's a great microphone
to pick that up I have generously decided
to take the meteorite back to my compound
for safe keeping oh you clever bastard this
isn't the media
what my friend was sad and I was just cheering
him up I think wolf was right maybe we could
be more than just scary villains oh my God
he wasn't bad he didn't betray his friends
oh that's a great twist [Music] I had him
switch it [Music] place
yes but that's a lamb where's that the old
switcheroo [Music]
oh blew up the compound [Music] but
this was stolen by the Oh by the Crimson Paw
I'm a flowering goodness that's my reptile
right there that's not what I'm talking about
yeah it was genius not only did I foil the
pig I got you to admit how much you care about
me sure yeah it did work who do you think
put that one push pop in the fridge ah
it's just twist upon twist here we good baby
it at all oh that was really adorable that
was fun all right all right well that was
a cute film indeed had a lot of fun with that
one a lot of uh pulling up the IMDb here for
the movie but yeah there was like a couple
little nods that are pretty it catched her
out that I'm not sure if I set it out loud
or not sometimes okay sometimes when I since
I'm editing and I'm like I did say it out
loud because I often have these thoughts going
through my brain that I sometimes forget to
express because I'm also trying to catch the
dialogue and there was so much whip fast dialogue
here throughout because it was like a fun
action-paced type of uh comedy here but like
they could say one thought I did have that
I definitely did not go into was they they
kept making the Clooney reference which obviously
is like Ocean's 11 Clooney but then my mind
started trailing off even more of oh that's
funny because Sam Rockwell starred in I believe
the movie's called Confessions of a dangerous
mind uh and that was a movie that I believe
I might have been George Clooney's directorial
debut uh directorial debut that might have
been his uh yeah it might have been but anyway
yeah George Clooney Sam Rockwell they have
indeed worked together before uh the bad guys
uh yeah I thought it was a really fun film
that actually had a really cool Vibrance about
it you felt a lot of influences in it throughout
I mean uh there was part of the animation
style that definitely reminded me of spider-verse
at times with the way the the movement and
the motion was in any type of action scene
I didn't have to be like a big action set
piece but even if it was just running away
from something for a brief moment of time
anything with like actual movement there was
this type of uh spider-verse animation quality
to it but overall I mean I think it's like
a just a really solid family-friendly movie
like that I think it was hilarious no no I
wouldn't say that uh there were some hilarious
moments and there it was a really funny film
and it's got a good message I think for for
the families out there for the kids to walk
away with you know one of my favorite motivational
speakers is Les Brown and one thing here's
where I really test myself I believe the quote
that he often would say is don't let someone
else's opinion of you become your reality
and that's essentially what the theme is of
this you know like obviously dealing with
a lot of with uh beyond that Beyond someone's
opinion of you uh it it exceeds that into
societal labeling uh is is one term for it
and I appreciate that they they deal with
that you know like a lot of times you are
dictated people is people can the another
term or self-fulfilling prophecy is you know
you you have a core belief of who you what
you might be who you might be and then through
that through through the the power of thought
you can it's that kind of thing where you
can go let me try to get my thoughts straight
here for one second I'm just kind of like
rambling through the power of your own beliefs
and it can be a very negative one you can
just land yourselves in situations where you
go see I told you I was right um and that
could often be something when you say something
like self-fulfilling prophecy it can be something
that has a negative association with it essentially
like with the law of attraction you know uh
you get what you really truly feel and believe
and these guys this group of the bad guys
uh by you know what they've been dictated
towards internally their whole life they have
become that so I think for kids to walk away
and adults I mean adults are a lot more in
their own way because they're adults they're
not as their brains are not as sponge heavy
they have become the the programming of childhood
that it it's it can be even harder to break
away from that mold because you have formed
a your I didn't expect to like I'm trying
to ride this line here between going a little
bit deep in my thoughts and keep it in light
but yeah you know like uh we're often we often
go about our lives I believe uh based off
of uh how uh or our identity like what we
perceive our identity to be and and we've
at the end of the day we can choose to form
our own identity so I think for kids to have
this message is is really valuable and important
and I you know I I know what it's like to
be a kid and watch something kind of goes
in one ear and out the other like oh it's
inspiring in the moment but then you don't
really do anything with it but I think it
is something that you can walk away with I
think it's a it's a real pleasure it's based
on a book huh imagine it probably goes a little
bit deeper there but yeah to to have to have
that I think is is really nice and there was
there were Parts about the movie itself that
while I think everyone did a great job with
their voice over work like to me the stand
the standouts would have to be let me make
sure I'm getting everyone right here yeah
Sam Rockwell is Wolf there's something so
natural about the way he does it like he's
he's perfectly suited for a character like
this and you know a lot of times he does play
like in real life he can't play like the cool
Suave guy but sometimes he is playing like
a sleazy dude and this was the the sleazy
side of Sam Rockwell that is charming and
appealing and attractive because he he knows
how to play that version too he knows how
to play all different layers of a sleazy guy
and I I think he did it really well like the
the Rhythm with his dialogue and the chemistry
that he forms with Mark Maron snake there
I got the the impression I could be way off
about this but it felt like they were at least
in the same recording booth like characters
like aquafina's tarantula or shark I feel
like they could have recorded separately but
there was something about the specific back
and forth again could be wrong about this
could just be a great handling of editing
and Direction where it felt like Sam Rockwell
Marin at times were in the same room together
bouncing off of each other so I thought they
had really great chemistry there zazi beats
as the fox character I thought was awesome
that felt like full spider verse in that moment
total Gwen Stacy uh when you do reveal that
she is the Crimson fox or Crimson paw I I
thought was a really nicely done reveal that
I'm sure was predictable for others like yeah
it's predictable in the journey it goes down
who cares it's a little bit predictable it's
a little bit formulaic I do not see Crimson
paw coming but yeah obviously the who who
is the guinea pig I don't know who that actor
is and I don't want Rich Richard iodine that
looks so familiar I gotta figure out what
have I seen this guy from he was zero in the
Mandalorian the Droid no I guess I haven't
actually seen any of the work that he's done
yeah just looks very familiar I might have
seen his face when I found out that he was
playing zero on the Mandalorian I thought
he did a I thought he did a great job too
albeit a bit of a predictable performance
uh not performance but a predictable character
reveal and there were times where I I've kind
of wanted the movie to just slow down and
settle in with a change of beat you know because
sometimes it was it was moving at such a fast
pace and while I really enjoyed it and had
fun sometimes when certain shifts would occur
with the plot or a plot reveal or a predicament
that they were in I felt they could have simbered
it a little bit longer like the one choice
that I thought they really settled in with
for a while was the whole concept of snake
and him not being friends and I thought I
had some really good turns and reveals in
the finale of it and I thought that's what
they really settled in with uh in terms of
that choice but sometimes it felt like something
big might happen some type of you know scenario
might occur that prevents itself a predicament
or a different type of plot development and
it would kind of just either get resolved
quickly or we're just moving along really
fast to the next thing and there were times
where I would kind of wanted to to settle
in a little bit more with some of those uh
some of those emotions because when we got
those tender moments I thought this when the
movie was really singing a little bit uh a
little bit higher because yeah it is such
a Dreamworks animation movie with the type
of whip zaniness that it is and and at the
end of the day you know like I I I saw Megamind
recently and and I was so impressed by that
and I'm more familiar with Pixar films than
I am with the DreamWorks movies and Megamind
I was so impressed with and I don't I wasn't
like watching this comparing it to Megamind
thinking that it should be like Megamind uh
because it's a very different type of film
because they're drawing so much from all kinds
of heist movies like you could see the Reservoir
Dogs influences you could see the Ocean's
11 influences there are times where you kind
of get like heat influences um you know the
the Ocean's Eleven The Pulp Fiction one at
the very beginning uh so it was a very different
kind of movie that they were doing and I guess
there are times I I would have liked to settle
in a little bit more with you know who they
are as characters rather than just quirks
especially with the rest of the gang like
if we just got a little bit more beats with
that because they gave it to Wolf and snake
but didn't really get that sense with shark
or tarantula and and I felt like the movie
it could have afforded a little bit of like
five minutes to just sort of get invest in
them as opposed to being you know just funny
characters or one note characters and and
I did find myself craving that just a little
bit more uh especially because you know they're
calling this the bad guys and they are part
of the main Ensemble and I felt like they
never really got above that one note I might
be being critical here just for the sake of
being critical because I'm in the review portion
of this video because it but I did find myself
actually at times kind of craving that a little
bit more often and yeah other than that though
I feel like this as much as I ramble on about
that it really didn't bother me that much
when I was watching it because the the main
thing it set out to do was have a have a nice
message be really funny entertaining have
some impressive animation and for a heist
movie to have this amount of like ridiculous
turns and reveals I really enjoy that I I
thought that was a nice surprise like especially
the reveals at the end with switching the
meter right around and then how a wolf actually
put the popsicle in the freezer to show that
he did see the good in him the whole time
it was clever I would have liked to have been
clued in a little bit earlier uh just on my
personal level to to know kind of what the
because it because I thought in the first
hour there were times it like the first 40
minutes I would say where if you're doing
a heist movie or anything with like these
kind of criminals and stuff you you one thing
I think you really got to sell are stakes
and you don't really get a sense of what's
really like okay yeah they might go to jail
but before they I you know what that might
be it I think I'll figure it out in the moment
is that when the heist actually began at the
beginning when they were first uh At the Gala
when you know wolf meets Fox we weren't we
didn't really get to know the characters all
that well other than just the surface notes
about them and so I wasn't quite emotionally
invested in them yet and so by the time we
got to the actual plot of them doing this
you know bad guy turn good Reformation so
that way they could uh pull up another Heist
when they were going there I think it was
progressing so fast that you know I I would
have liked just a tad bit more of that extra
feel of of like oh no no you're you're you're
don't don't pull off that heist in front of
all those people wolf like now you're turning
you this is your chance to turn good you know
like a little bit more of that conflict could
have just been that much more palpable just
like a tad inch it's like a little bit of
extra salt you know what I mean forgive me
for not speaking clearly right now I'm figuring
out some of my emotions as I'm talking about
this one of the setbacks from time to time
when you talk about a movie immediately after
watching it uh and sometimes I'm sharp sometimes
I'm not but that uh that some of some of this
is like things I'm just thinking about right
now like it's one of those things where in
the immediate moment I wasn't actually that
bothered by it but in the in the reflection
of it just thinking about what could have
made this movie had that much more of an extra
punch of an emotional punch which would have
just further enhanced the the comedy stuff
and and the exciting action Parts is having
a little bit more of that extra emotional
punch and I really feel like five more minutes
just a little bit spread out could have done
that just a little bit more but it has a stance
who gives a [__] honestly it's fun it's
a fun family movie at the end of the day it's
a fun family movie and it delivers like for
the audience at this movie's setting out to
do to to deliver for I think they didn't I
think they did an excellent job and I could
see why it's become uh a hit did it do well
at the box office why are people suddenly
talking about this movie I I feel like this
completely I didn't hear about this until
other people this week started telling me
about it I've never heard of this movie till
today holy [__] 248 million worldwide
this movie did all right I've never heard
of this movie kind of surprising to me all
right then well there we are I have talked
about the bad guys I enjoyed the bad guys
uh it was a really fun-filled animated action
Heist film thank you guys so much for being
here much love to everyone at the reject Nation
please feel free to show your support feel
free to contribute hear my tour patreon page
it's kind of ironic to say it that way thank
you so much for being here and uh I'll talk
with you all soon [Music]